what if I told you that the world of
Terminator 2 is here no I'm not talking
about sentient Ai and apocalyptic robots
I'm speaking of liquid-based robots that
can transform from solid to liquid
States change shapes at will and
jailbreak well the future is here
crazy right well let me tell you how
this science fiction came to life a team
of scientists has created tiny robots
made of shape-shifting liquid metal that
can move from a solid to a liquid state
and back again making them the most
versatile robots out there and the
secret to their success magnetoactive
phase transitional matter or mptm
magnetic fields and gallium by
controlling the magnetic fields these
scientists can control the movement and
shape of the liquid metal robots this
opens up a world of possibilities in
biomedical and Engineering Technologies
from targeted drug delivery to Circuit
Assembly but why liquid metal robots
when we already have soft malleable
robots the answer is simple these liquid
metal robots have the speed and fluidity
of a liquid and the strength and
stability of a solid so how did this
groundbreaking discovery start it was a
joint effort from U.S and Chinese
scientists King Yuan Wang Cheng
they all published a proof of concept
paper titled magnetoactive liquid solid
face transitional matter in the matter
Journal that may just give rise to
liquid robots the rigid body of
conventional robots limits what they can
do and where they can go so that is
given rise to people looking for
soft-bodied robots these soft-bodied
robots can reshape and deform their
bodies to move in several ways to get a
job done however there's a problem here
because these robots are technically
solid they can't pass spaces smaller
than their body if for example we needed
these robots to enter a tiny hole to fix
a machine that wouldn't be possible it
is because of this that scientists
started messing around with liquid
robots these machines would be capable
of splitting into different pieces
fitting into small spaces and coming
back together however yet again there's
a problem with this liquids are pretty
weak because they deform when they take
too much pressure pressure limiting what
these liquid-based robots can do so an
international team of scientists mix
solid microscopic magnetic particles in
gallium a popular liquid metal so they
could get the best of the solid and
liquid world this is what they call
magnetoactive phase transitional matter
also known as mptm this substance is
remarkable because you can use magnets
to push and pull the magnetic particles
in mptm thus causing the mptm to
shapeshift in the same way that liquids
and soft-bodied robots do also the mptm
can change from solid to liquid and
liquid to solid just like the T-1000 in
Terminator 2. however what makes this
truly possible is the liquid metal
gallium the scientists used you see at
sea level this metal melts just before
it hits 30 degrees Celsius to put this
simply this metal has a melting point
low enough that it melts in your hand
but high enough to stay solid at room
temperature to get the gallium to become
liquid the scientists use an oscillating
mag magnetic field that keeps changing
between the North and South magnetic
poles this causes those magnetic
particles to oscillate in the gallium
generating heat and causing it to stay
in a liquid state using magnets the team
of scientists can make the gallium
transform into whatever shape they want
and move in whatever Direction they want
and to turn the metal back to Solid the
magnetic field is simply turned off and
the liquid cools back to solid still you
should know that the mptp wasn't the
first solid to liquid substance made the
past attempts were a bit gooey to say
the least this made them a lot more
limited in usage and practicality I mean
think about it it's easier for a liquid
in the consistency of say oil to pass
through tiny spaces than jelly in one of
the initial attempts to test the new
liquid-based robot researchers
successfully integrated a tiny led into
a circuit that was difficult to access
by using the robot as a versatile screw
the robot liquefied and then entered
into the threaded opening before
solidifying effectively securing two
plastic plates together I mean it was
kind of a one-trick robot but the job
did get done the researchers have also
demonstrated the potential of the mptm
as a medical device as well in one
experiment the mptm was introduced into
the stomach in its solid form then
melted to envelop a foreign object and
securely grasped it the metal was then
removed by guiding it out with a magnet
another demonstration saw the mptm
deliver medication to a specific
location in the stomach where it melted
to release the drug and then discreetly
departed much like a spy at this point I
should point out that all these
demonstrations were done in fake
stomachs for now all of these are still
in the experimentation stage but the
possibilities are Limitless these robots
could enter the body and Target cancer
cells and kill them discreetly without
the need for dramatic bouts of
chemotherapy or even you know be used
for Espionage however despite the
boundless application for mptm the
internal temperature of the human body
is higher than the melting point of
gallium this means that if this ever
became an actual medical procedure the
scientists would need a different metal
but don't worry these researchers are
already ahead of us as they've
discovered a gallium alloy that can stay
solid in the human body finally the
demonstration that was the craziest of
all was the prison break these
researchers made a cute tiny robot LEGO
looking person from mptm and put it
behind bars you should know that this
Innovative robot doesn't just contain
gallium instead it's been equipped with
an alloy that combines three other
powerful elements iron neodymium and
Boron this unique combination makes it
highly responsive to magnetic fields
giving it a distinctive Edge over others
in its class with all these properties
the robot could melt down Slither
through the bars and return to its
original state Terminator style all in
10 minutes at this point I should add
that with the proper magnetic field
calibration this mini machine can spin
at a rapid 1500 revolutions per minute
jump 20 times its height and move at a
speed of one meter per second these
impressive capabilities might not quite
match the T-1000 from the movies but
it's still a remarkable bundle of energy
so if you were worried about
post-apocalyptic robots well your fear
may not be far off on a more serious
note the mptm would be a game changer in
many Industries requiring precise
actions in hard to access places this is
all thanks to magnetism Cheng Fang pan a
co-author of the mptm paper and engineer
at the Chinese University of Hong Kong
had this to say giving robots the
ability to switch between liquid and
solid States endows them with more
functionality thus the next logical
thing is to promote these materials to
solve peculiar medical and Engineering
problems the power of magnetism hasn't
only helped in the creation of mptm a
shape-shifting slime has also been
created a little similar to mptm this
dark-colored magnetic blob has been
making waves on social media and has
even been compared to Flubber the
eponymous substance from the 1997 sci-fi
film but let me assure you this is not
an April Fool's joke this is real
scientific research according to
Professor Lee Zhang of the Chinese
University of Hong Kong who co-created
the Slime which contains magnetic
particles the magnetic particles in the
Slime allow it to be manipulated into
traveling rotating or forming onc shapes
when external magnets are applied the
ultimate goal is to deploy it like a
robot but for now it's still considered
fundamental research magnetic slime has
unique viscoelastic properties meaning
it can behave like a solid or a liquid
it's made of a mixture of borax alcohol
polyvinyl and particles of neodymium
magnet the researchers envisioned that
magnetic slime could be helpful in the
medical field for example in reducing
harm from a small swallowed battery
still this slime is not without dangers
while the magnetic particles in the
Slime are toxic the researchers coated
the slime in a layer of silica to form a
protective layer however however
Professor Zhang warns that safety
depends on how long it's kept inside the
body finally the researchers also
mentioned that pigments or dyes could be
added to the Slime which is currently an
opaque brown black Hue to make it more
colorful but the shape-shifting
substance Saga doesn't just end there it
has been going on for a while in 2017
scientists made a groundbreaking
discovery in electronics Soft Robotics
and flexible displays they found a way
to morph liquid metal into 2D shapes
using an electrical charge making it
possible to program and control the
position and shape of the liquid
dynamically Professor sriram subramanian
head of the interact Lab at the
University of Sussex explained liquid
metals are an extremely promising class
of materials for deformable applications
their unique properties include
voltage-controlled surface tension High
liquid state conductivity and liquid
solid face transition at room
temperature in the same year research
engineers at Carnegie Mellon University
he created a metal alloy that exists in
a liquid state at room temperature and
has the potential to revolutionize the
world of electronics group has been
working on engineering new types of
materials that are soft and stretchable
and could be used for applications and
wearable Computing and also machines and
robots that can physically interact with
humans these are materials that could
operate kind of like artificial muscle
or materials that can reconfigure their
shape and their stiffness simply we've
also been looking at uses of liquid
metal for a soft actuators and materials
that have these shape-shifting
properties the alloy created by
researchers Carmel majidi Michael Dickey
and James visman is made from a
combination of indium and gallium and
only requires a voltage of 1 to 10 volts
to form or break a circuit also in early
2020 a team of researchers at Cinque
University in China created a liquid
metal material that was so light it
could float on water the researchers
believe this material could be used to
construct lightweight exoskeletons and
shape-shifting robots despite its low
density the liquid metal materials still
maintained excellent conformability
stiffness electric conductivity and
variety under temperature regulation it
may take some time but these Innovations
could change the way we think about
Metal forever maybe not the apocalyptic
end of the world scenario of Terminator
or the incredible Espionage scenario of
Mission Impossible at least not yet but
in a way that would bring smiles to the
faces of sick people who need medical
attention pushing us further into a
better healthier and of course more
fabulous World join us next time and
click on the videos you see on your
screen